all right what's up y'all as always
welcome to another live stream
tonight we're going to be addressing the
racist statements of Ellen White as well
as the Adventist Church's pathetic
attempts to spin and defend them if you
will
um I recently uploaded a video about
this and as expected Adventist showed up
with the same tired excuses they
inherited from the SDA Church by way of
f d nickel who in the 1950s uh 1951
wrote a book titled amalgamation where
he attempted to address these
embarrassing statements by Ellen White
so we're going to get into the details
of this how he was influenced by Dr
Marsh in the 1950s and the tensions that
were Rising within the SDA Church due to
these statements
Adventist Paul just want you to think
that we're the clueless critics
Liars who are misrepresenting what she
said uh haven't read her fully uh Making
Connections where there are none and so
on but is this the case
tonight we're going to see who has and
hasn't done their homework and who is
being honest about the facts and who's
simply parroting the script that they
had been fed by the Adventist industrial
complex
okay
because one side is actually looking at
the full scope of things
the evolution no pun intended
of how this has changed over the years
and how the 1950s was a pivotal time but
the Adventist Church was not born in the
1950s
so remember that
with me to discuss always always a
pleasure to have these two guys here
with me they are not strangers to the
show Pastor EJ Thunder Larson CMB the
Ambassador gentlemen thank you for being
here how are we doing
lessons lessons bro
doing well good to be here with you
again and of course with CMD always
on these discussions and conversations
theological issues and that caused
issues surrounding adventures and
contrast
historical Christianity that the three
all again Brothers
always always stoked to have you guys
here how you doing CNB doing great
Brothers I'm glad to be here tonight
what's up to everybody in the chat to
see some people from all over the place
and see Joey from England to see uh
someone uh from Ireland as well too
someone from Idaho let's go to other
places in the uh United States and
worldwide so God bless you all love to
see you love to hang out with you
Brothers man uh tight tonight is going
to be a little rough but uh we'll make
it through you know God willing so we'll
be all right totally you know it's funny
you real quick it's funny you mentioned
um Ireland and these other places
answering adventism has crossed 25
countries as of as of uh last week I
think it was 25 countries 25 countries
that's just it's just crazy to think
about because it's like I'm a guy here
you know in my bonus room at my house
um it was just kind of passionate about
reaching Seventh-day Adventist and then
I'm able to reach 25 countries of people
or we are rather it's not even just me
there's a collective unit
um involved in that so praise God so
we're going to start by reading a few
comments though folks
before we get into a presentation that
CMB is going to give I want to respond
to a few of the comments on the recent
video I uploaded for people to see
themselves some of these common defenses
as well as a quote from SDA Pioneer
Uriah Smith regarding Ellen White's
amalgamation statements now we're going
to be looking at more quotes tonight
than just the amalgamation quotes
because there are plenty
but I want to look at that before we get
going as well and like I said after that
CMB is going to take the reins he's
going to present we're going to look at
those quotes as well as a number of
others and then we'll discuss some of
the historical development as well that
led to the current defenses that the SDA
Church uses so with that being the case
let's look at the first comments
so this guy has two comments
Anthony he says
spiritual things are spiritually
understood if one carefully read the
statement pertaining to the amalgamation
of man and beasts one would understand
or write what the statement is conveying
we all know that the coupling of a human
and a beast cannot bring forth an animal
nor a human neither a creature being
part human and part Beast well one thing
I'll say here is I didn't even get into
that aspect in my video so I expected
all them to show up again with the
script and just anytime this Topic's
mentioned uh what are the talking points
just throw them out I didn't even bring
up creating a hybrid whatever in the
video so he's just throwing out one of
the common expectations that people are
going to say which we're going to get
into this tonight to see if that is what
she's actually saying but then he
continues again the idea of whites
having their congregation for whites and
blacks having their congregation for
blacks is misunderstood consider the era
back then when racism was rampant the
council was given that the word needed
to be given to the white persons as well
as the black person and since slavery
was also horrible there will be mistrust
between blacks and whites which would
have been a stumbling blockchain
person's salvation that's the reason for
the separate congregations back then but
it should not be so now because there's
no Jew or Gentile with God no black nor
white nor greater or lesser human being
free made us all Psalm 100. we just need
to gain the right understanding of the
writings and God can give us such
well at least you rightly recognized
Anthony that the fact that there's a
black conference in a white conference
does not mirror uh the kingdom of God
that there shouldn't be such a thing in
the fact that there still is today
should send up at least somewhat of a
red flag
but EJ what are your thoughts on if you
carefully read the statement that's not
what she's saying
now he doesn't get into the specific
defenses here like some of these other
commenters were but what are your
thoughts on that are we not reading
things carefully
of course we read them carefully and
every some of the Adventists before
1947 into 1951 who wrote a long white
statements carefully
they unanimously understood them the
same
way so when she first made the statement
in 1864
and then coming down through to
1931 was the first time they tried to
reinterpret it uh an Adventist by the
name of George McCree price
he first
suggested in order to make it more
palatable and agree with what science
was understanding better than that
animals and humans can't procreate he
was the one who first suggested that
they add amalgamation of man and of
beasts as a means of of making it with
this guy is in here
um and so again you know it is not
possible with misreading the statement
or not really carefully everyone
unanimously for the 83 years of the
existence of this building from 1864
through to 1947 1951 it was unanimous
it meant
man and humans interbred and produce
yeah that's how it could universally
understood an adventure
universally defended until science was
refuting their mature and otherwise then
they started to try what is happening
now and so we have already here from all
of them it is them who have been
properly read it I know it is the
reinterpretation which we get into as we
go into the program
well that's what I think is so funny and
folks we're going to look at these
quotes tonight so you're going to see
we're not just talking out the sides of
our neck here um But the irony of this
comment it's like Anthony then everyone
in your denomination for like 90 years
didn't know how to read it apparently
they were all clueless they were all
lost your whole denomination was lost on
this topic until uh the 50s okay
I don't useless I don't know um but that
was his this person's YouTube name again
rather long comments here has a couple
of them
he says this is the worst interpretation
of her writing and deliberately so she
wrote the amalgamation of man and Beast
not the amalgamation of man with Beast
this guy's been reading the ADL article
or FD Nichols book two entirely very
very different things learn to read
English properly a bit of a challenge
for Americans
how so many get this wrong I'll never
know so many think that the Giants came
from the union of fallen angels and
humans in direct contradiction of the
Bible Christ said that there was no
marriage between angels in heaven and
yet somehow they could down here really
why did they stop none of this had to do
with my video by the way why aren't they
still doing it now and Giants abound
it's because the sons of God were those
that worshiped God and the daughters of
the sons of men were those who did not
worship God Genesis 6 2 has no
connection with Genesis 6 4. ever notice
how the animals went into the ark the
clay Animals by seven and the unclean by
twos
if God had created everything and
declared it very good how is now one of
the one law of animals clean and one one
lot unclean through the amalgamation of
Beast with Beast so this is getting into
what you were saying EJ about the
rewording of the of the phrase that's
why they're unclean and still are today
a lot of comments here not backed up
with anything but rumor how this woman
who was the starter of Oakwood
University for African Americans in
Huntsville Alabama in a Time 1896 and
space where racism was and probably
still his Rife is lambasted as a racist
is beyond me you're no scholar no
Theologian just another virtue signaler
trying to go through everything with
your virtues signaling glasses with a
supposed Christian tent
try and do better and be the man Christ
wants you to be misrepresenting
something is also known as bearing false
witness the ninth of the Ten
Commandments the irony
of this coming
the irony we're not going to get into a
ton of the details here because we're
going to save that for when we get into
the presentation but folks I want you to
see the sort of defenses that you're
going to hear when you bring this up
they're all going to say these same
things you're reading it wrong it didn't
say hybrid humans that's specifically
why I didn't even mention it in the
video I only covered one aspect of the
claim which there are multiple aspects
as we will see tonight I only covered
one of them because I wanted to see if
Adventists would even listen they all
commented on there she's not talking
about a hybrid human why didn't even
bring that aspect up in the video I
talked about race mixing because as
you're going to see it's also
miscegenation that she was talking about
not just man with animals creating other
breeds I don't know fellas I'm one of
these mixed race amalgamations if you
will so maybe I'm just not smart enough
to grasp what's being said
um maybe that's the issue
then NBA 2K 2 King 670 whatever NBA
said
um so when she said amalgamation she
didn't mean mixing this ethnicity with
that ethnicity stretch
the other so-called supporting
statements you pulled from another book
has nothing to do with what she said
about the antediluvian people okay halt
folks in that video the point that I was
making in quoting from separate Works
yes I'm aware that the amalgamation
statements were not connected directly
to what the statements that she said
regarding race mixing or or not marrying
during Antebellum slavery days that
wasn't the point the point was to show
in that specific video all this stuff is
supposedly attributed to God God is the
one that said this so at one time if you
went again if you go against God's word
that's a sin if God tells you to do
something and you go against it that is
a sin so if God said for a specific
period of time
black people can't marry white people
and you went against that you were
sinning that's the point
saying oh that was only for back then
oh okay yeah that really helps that's
kind of like when they say which we'll
see with Genesis 6 is oh well I know it
was race mixing back then but it was
only back then
it was only it was only when they were
race mixing back then as if that somehow
compartmentalizes God's racism that
makes it better
he continues that's a different subject
but when she said amalgamation of man
and Beast she's not talking about mixing
man and Beast to create hybrid man-beast
creatures she was referencing the sons
of God marrying the daughters of men so
this is the other nickel argument here
that is the sons of Seth and the
daughters of Cain and the Bible does in
fact state in that that in Genesis 6
right before the flood and beasts
intermingling with different beasts you
know like ligers so God flooded the
Earth because of lions and tigers mating
you know something he would have had to
have created them to have an innate
ability to do amongst there's their kind
that that frustrated him and so he
flooded the Earth because of ligers
this is lazy research
or biased with a false premise already
when she talked about how white people
should not marry black people we have to
remember this was during the time of
extreme racism and slavery remember
folks these words that she said
barricaded by thus saith the Lord God
speaking through clay never wrote a
single sentence of heresy they're not
her own words it's not merely the
opinion of sister white you go against
her words you're going against the
spirit of God
that's what's in Focus notice none of
these commenters are actually oh no that
was just wise counsel she was giving no
no no this is supposed to be God
speaking
she was trying to protect people
essentially those kids who were born as
mixed race because it can cause an
outrage amongst the people who were
already racist
for a racist white man to see a
mixed-race baby could be Troublesome and
for one to be born mixed race at the
time could be confusing to them too as
to why so much hate from a race that he
or she is half of those times were
different from our times now
any comments on that fellas before
moving to our uh well we have our last
person and then I'm going to bring out
actually a
a real winner of some comments from
another gentleman and then we're going
to transition to CMB any thoughts on
this folks
I think your question or your challenge
or uh comment anyway at the beginning
was right we're going to find out who's
done their homework yeah I'd say
EJ any thoughts
yeah it's basically the same thing um
they
they never miss they always
approach you or enter the conversation
kicking down the door and
you know just
kind of shop and throw it out all of
these accusations and
draw mind and I'm home and of all works
until you start to unearth
the contention
and then they have been a lot of Humble
Pie and I try to back pedal and do all
kinds of
spins and and cognitive dissonance fuse
that still try to maintain the sins of
coherence and so again when we
systematically and historically go
through the fact
that persons will see who's just you
know just jump in the history
conclusions and accusations without
properly
studying the issue while and
investigating the facts yeah
uh miles real quick um go ahead uh just
to address one of the questions that was
under how could the founder of Oakwood
College uh in Huntsville B raise the
same way the presidents of Oakland
College
from back in the day they didn't have uh
I think the first black president of my
history searching correctly as I am an
Oakwood grad
um you know uh if it serves me correctly
the first black president I believe was
jail Moran
um and before that there were white
presidents of the colleges and
universities and black students and
staff couldn't come into the office in
certain in certain instances so
I don't know is that possible you tell
me huh you'll have to figure that out
and not just that but that's irrelevant
because
you can look systematically which one
guy we're going to look at here in a
moment he's going to harp on
have you read sister white
systematically on this meaning looking
at all of what she says on the topic
folks I'll challenge you tonight which
we're going to look at some of it I
challenge you do a systematic study on
what she said in regards to other races
of people and their learning
capabilities please do yeah and why why
you'd want to set up a just because you
set up a university in a predominantly
you know colored area doesn't
automatically mean therefore you don't
have certain you could want to go in
there and be like oh man these primitive
people we need to educate them and we
need to get them you know you can have
all sorts of motives that doesn't mean
anything
go ahead
and make her on that
that was exactly the most of why it was
founded Ellen White House found a lot of
viral schools and training programs in
in the South especially Mississippi for
that very reason because she supported
segregation and wrote extensively on it
that they should be segregated and even
in those black churches and institutions
because of her view that that blacks
were
um virtually morally intellectually
Etc inferior uh to whites that whites
should be chosen as leaders in all those
instances and all of those institutions
in fact it is because of Ellen White's
eight-seated racist statements that
there exists
racial segregation and
uh black and white as the conferences in
North America
and so that is not something far-fetch
Ellenwood was very altruistic as white
were gaining freedoms and Liberties and
she saw them basically
as if I may put it this way cash out to
the weekend on the system
try to reach them to advance
she makes that clear over and over and
how she approached it and so that is
yes no and we're going to get into that
tonight so people will see for
themselves and the receipts are here
trust yeah
so then Jason Thomas he commented a
bunch on the the video we're going to
look at a couple of them here
he said he's responding to me here
because I I asked him I said show us in
the Bible Well he says you wrote show us
that race mixing was the chief of sins
that caused God to flood the Earth
that was my question because that was my
question in the video because that was
the point of of the video God supposedly
flooded the Earth because certain races
of people had the image of God defaced
in them show me this from scripture so
then he says the Bible says in quotes
like the person previously brought up
Genesis 6 1-7
when man began to multiply on the face
of the land and daughters were born to
them the sons of God saw that the
daughters of man were attractive and
they took as their wives any they chose
then the Lord said my my spirit shall
not abide on in man forever for he is
flesh for his day shall be 120 years the
Nephilim were on the earth in those days
and those afterward when the sons of God
came into the daughters of man and they
bored children to them they were the
Mighty Men Who were of old the men of
renown the Lord saw that the wickedness
of man was great in the earth and that
every uh intention of the thoughts of
his heart was only evil continually and
the Lord regretted that he had made uh
made man on the earth and it grieved him
to his heart sorry I copied and pasted
this from uh one of those sites that has
a uh that puts the little letters for
the annotations and the footnotes forgot
to get them all out so the Lord said I
will blot out man whom I have created
from the face of the land man and
animals and creeping things and birds of
the heavens for I am sorry that I have
made them fellas where and layers that
say anything about race mixing
nowhere
it's just the Assumption as you're going
to see in the next slide where he I
highlighted his emphasis to
what he emphasized
the race mixing that was being referred
to was the sons of God and the daughters
of men there we go there's the FD nickel
argument you can see that this
combination caused evilness
there is a principle of God that says to
not be unequally yoked there again is
the FD nickel argument it was it was
being unequally yoked God flooded the
world because the results that came from
this mixing in the previous chapter of
the book you quoted Ellen White wrote
what she meant
quote Seth was a more noble stature than
Cain or Abel and resembled Adam more
than any of his other Sons the
descendants of Seth had separated
themselves from the wicked descendants
of Cain they cherished the knowledge of
God's Will and then he emphasizes while
the ungodly race of Cain had no respect
for God and His sacred Commandments but
when man multiplied upon the Earth the
descendants of Seth saw that the
daughters of The Descendants that came
were very beautiful and they departed
from God and displeased him by taking
wives as they chose to the idolatrous
race of Cain
then he continues on to the next page
again his emphasis there the descendants
of Seth were called the sons of God the
descends of Cain the sons of men as the
sons of God mingled with the sons of men
they became corrupt and by intermarriage
with them there's that unequally yoked
lost
through the influence of their wives
their peculiar holy character and United
with the sons of Cain in their idolatry
many cast aside the fear of God and
trampled upon his Commandments
close quote then he says clearly the
race mixing she was referring to was the
ungodly race of Cain and the descendants
of Seth did you consider this context
so it's literally just the FD nickel
argument did Genesis 6 say anything
about being unequally yoked did it say
anything about race mixing did it answer
the question
no this is just Ellen White having to be
defended so you're gonna quote the proof
text where she supposedly is just
pulling proof text from the Bible and
then just inserting a bunch of things
yes Jason I've considered the context
I've read this book have you I've talked
with you before and you've told me that
you're not very versed on Ellen White
I've read thousands of pages of Ellen
White have you
have you because you're just using the
FD nickel argument which ironically in
his final comment says the first one to
plead is case seems right until another
comes and cross-examines him Proverbs 18
17 how ironic Jason
good job in connecting two completely
unrelated quotes again missing the point
of why I was quoting both of the things
I wasn't saying that one was both were
talking about amalgamation
I was pointing to multiple things that
talk about race mixing
her comments about refraining from mixed
marriages was because of the level of
hatred and racism that existed in the
1800s and early 1900s again no no Jason
it was not Her counsel
her comments it's not her comments
you're missing it my friend
it's God God is saying this
that's the issue God did not give
counsel for a for during the Antebellum
Period that if you intermarry you're
sinning
that's what you're saying that's what
you're defending I'm sorry I know I'm
getting worked up but it's just it's
laughable it's laughable that you have
to defend this
it was wise counsel for the time no no
it wasn't just counsel when God speaks
it is authoritative Jason
that means to go against what God Said
for a just a small period of time since
you're saying it's just a small period
of time it was sinful to do that
it was sinful to go against what God
said it's not just counsel like advice
like God's saying well I wouldn't
recommend this like a financial
accountant
this is God we're talking about and this
is supposedly coming from God which was
the point in my video is that God did
not give counsel that it was wrong to
race mix during Antebellum slavery that
it's sinful to do so
there's a book called amalgamation by
Francis d nickel provided by the white
estate if anyone's interested in hearing
the truth of this matter
quote prove all things close quote
the irony the irony
so we're going to talk about that
tonight and people are going to see and
Jason we're going to take you up on your
offer and prove all things
and you're right the first one to plead
his case seems right the Adventist
Church pled this first not me Jason
you're right it does sound right when
you just go to FD nickel who folks you
think FD nickel had any bias
he was sent out on a task to
specifically deal with this problem
that's definitionally a bias
so we're supposed to go to FD nickel who
was sent out on a on a on a goose hunt
on an egg hunt
to literally find a solution for a
problem like they're notorious for doing
investigative judgment you name it they
always have to Pivot it always has to be
some malleable thing
so we're supposed to believe him but
don't believe the people who are
analyzing being critical thinking you
know that doesn't sound right I don't
think God is is I don't think God was
saying that he flooded the Earth because
of certain races of people furthermore
how does inner marriage Brothers how
does
being unequally yoked produce a
different race of people
oh man and that's that's that's the
Ridiculousness of it because
when when you follow the argument up to
today then
we should definitely get the same
results
if we accept that
this
amalgamation of of races with races are
save people with unsafe people
Adventists with non-adventus Christians
with non-christians is what is this what
Ellen White calls his base crime that
produced confused feces that I rated God
that eventually caused the flood that
still happens today
Adventist Marine on Adventists
Christians marry non-christians
why aren't we seeing the same reaction
why aren't we seeing that it's still the
base crime that warrants total
annihilation of the race with the
exception of fuel that are pure and holy
Etc
again it shows you that even better
defense does not make sense because the
same things are happening today probably
on a grander scale
Christians are marrying non-christians
on the ground this year
Adventists are Marian known Adventists
on a grander scale if this is what is
being condemned
that brought the flood
that angered God and he could not take
it anymore
it's happening on a grand scale
why don't we see the same reaction to
this base amalgamation that is going on
today it just doesn't make sense
and we never see where where Northern
Adventists marrying a non-advance
producer all different race that demands
destruction we don't see where a
Christian Marrying an unbeliever
producing produces a an Amalgamated
transmogrified race of of people that
warrants destruction
we don't see it so again following the
argument and the solution logically
through prove the absurdity of it
because again it is still happening
and yet we don't see the Vengeance we
don't see the floods we don't see the
creation of this the this this this
grotesque race of people that warrants
total annihilation
well and you have to remember too is
we're going to see in the quote she says
that this act marred the image of God in
these The Offspring
so you can't just tell me that being
unequally yoked Mar so all people who
were born out of wedlock or all people
who the mother's a Believer the father
is not they're unequally yoked their
children have the image of God marred in
them
no a nice try nice try
then we got this here folks which
this was on a different video but I
thought you know this is perfect to
conjoin onto this and before I get to it
no Adventists I'm not saying that all
seventh Adventists are like this no I'm
not saying that this guy is a
spokesperson for Seventh-Day adventism
but what he says here is consistent with
what Ellen White was claiming
that's why I want to show this and I
want people to see this sort of vile and
filth that this sort of thinking and
sort of thing can produce
so this guy's been blocked from the
channel because he's disgusting
but before he got blocked these are why
he got blocked he left a long chain of
comments he left us on the video of an
interview that I had with April Chapman
over at the standard of Truth podcast
April is an African-American woman and
this is what he proceeded to comment on
the videos and this is an Adventist he
says Mr miles
so how many more black women are you
going to depend on to get your toxic
message out
firstly Ellen White made it clear that
her writing should be considered as one
would scripture meaning gather all the
writings presented on a certain topic
subject or doctrine and evaluate it in
its entirety friend yes or no
the irony
did you or did you not gather all that
was written on the topics you wish to
address
second
if your desperate attempt to spread the
word against adventism you had to do
what black men accuse black women of
it is no secret that black woman would
jump at the opportunity to speak to
white men
you couldn't approach a white woman
sir she approached me
because she has Adventist family members
why are you focused in on skin color I
don't care what the guess skin color is
the person has to be one black and two a
woman well we've seen how that's panned
out because this interview took place a
little while ago
it's not possible to be interviewed by a
white male did you know black men
consider black women at the bottom of
the rankings in humanity It's All Over
YouTube don't take my word for it it's
not what I say but what black men have
to say about black women
so you don't have to Target the lowest
and most toxic of humanity to get your
toxic message out correct nice try Mr
miles you and I are the exact opposite
that's the only true thing you've said
so far sir
you left adventism and joined the reform
faith I left the reform Faith to become
an Adventist
shall we debate the Westminster
Confession of Faith starting on page 71
to see how it contradicts other texts in
the same volume
no sir I have no interest in talking
with you you are vile disgusting and
it's very obvious that you're not a part
of the reform Faith or The Wider Body of
Christ because if you were and you were
part of my church you'd be under church
discipline
because this is disgusting but see folks
this is the sort of thing and I'm not
saying that this guy's necessarily it's
hard to believe that well then again the
internet kind of brings out all sorts of
things in people but
people like this
probably read The Ellen white stuff and
they agree with it
this guy's Proud To Be An Adventist
Adventist come get your boy
there's his handle
public information not saying to Doc's
the guy but
disgusting
let's see how um if there's any rebuke
here all right open Rubik is better than
secret love my friends so let's see what
you guys are going to do balls in your
court yes yes
nasty like what in the world are you
talking about get off YouTube dude
you're getting your understanding of
the worth of people off of YouTube
and you're professing to be a Christian
this is why we're addressing stuff like
this Adventist because of people like
this guy
so with all that out there now that
you've heard the common responses
oh no she was referring to being
unequally yoked in marriage
no no no
like Jason claimed by race you have to
utilize the word how it was understood
in Ellen White's day which simply meant
types of people
yet ironically he doesn't apply that
same standard with the word amalgamation
which was utilized in Ellen's day as
we're going to see to refer to race
mixing and beats around uh
um
and it referred to certain races of
people like
that's what I referred to as producing
Offspring who were Amalgamated a mixture
miscegenation sub-human
you've heard their excuse that race
mixing was in reference to the
descendants of Seth and the ungodly race
of Cain
you've heard the Council on inner
marriages with simply wise counsel for
the day due to political climate
that's all she was saying that's all she
was saying so we're going to test this
we're going to take a look at Ellen
White's quotes as well as statements
from a number for contemporaries
not SDA apologists 70 80 90 years
removed and we're going to see how the
early sdas understood Ellen's words
and we're going to show that these
modern excuses that SDA apologies give
conflict with how others at that time
understood the statements
CMB the floor is yours sir
um and it will be for the majority I'll
have a couple parts to splice in if you
don't have the information already in
your slides but if you do the floor is
yours sir if you would like to present
okay
you are muted brother oh there we go
okay thank you very much uh brother
miles and thank you for allowing us on
your platform again on inviting us on
you know so this is uh this will be
interesting
you know um before we get going um I got
a shout out the BK apologist he's in the
chat right now so shout out to my bro uh
we've been doing uh this thing online
for some years now
um and he's actually one of the first uh
few people that encouraged me to uh
share my testimony as a former seven-day
Adventist
um and I had noticed how to do this
stuff publicly you know um and uh I
didn't realize that there was such a
need for it you know so uh if you got
anything and you wanted to blame blame
him I kidding all right so love you bro
uh and we did this this is actually a
remix of uh of one of the um uh the the
presentation that we did on the BK
apologist channel so uh we may not get
through every single thing tonight uh
there's more information to be had uh
please check out the BK apologist
Channel as well too uh this is the title
uh this is the thumbnail so you can find
it fairly easily hidden race Doctrine
SDA uh you put that in your YouTube
search bar and you'll find it
now um before we get going
um I want to make sure that we're
abundantly clear about something right
um we do not have hate Seventh-Day
Adventists I don't okay miles does not
and EJ does not we don't hate sdas okay
um what we don't like is the system okay
the system is not
um it's it's broken it's corrupt okay
and if we're gonna be honest we have to
be honest and take a good hard look at
some things and before you do that
anything that you buy into any
philosophy and world view and religious
freedom for whatever whatever okay
um you have to be able to make sure that
it stands up to scrutiny truth can stand
scrutiny
okay so if you're taking a look at it
um do so
um honestly and see what sticks okay if
it's truth it's God's truth and it can
handle it if it's not truth some things
are going to be found out to be dross
and
hey and all this other stuff that bible
talks about okay it's not gonna stand so
with that said
um let's jump right into it okay um
we're already almost uh 40 minutes into
it 45 minutes so let's just jump into it
guys all right so this is uh SD belief
um advantage.org and also uh for those
who say that we are just saying things
out of context in the green at the
bottom of your screen I provide
um the the receipts that's where you can
find them screenshot them if you need to
write uh watch the screen stream again
find them okay so that's there so
advantage.org beliefs um this is the
gift of Prophecy it says the test the
scriptures testify that one of the gifts
of the holy spirit is prophecy this gift
is an identifying Mark of the remnant
church and we believe it was manifested
in the ministry of Ellen G white her
writings speak with prophetic Authority
y'all caught that and uh provide Comfort
guidance instruction and correction to
the church they also make clear that the
Bible is a standard by which all
teaching and experience must be tested
okay y'all know this all right
um this was alluded to earlier selected
messages book one page 27 in these
letters which I write in the testimonies
at their and guys wedding testimonies
writing's a villain white or
specifically the volumes of uh the
testimony books there you go okay so in
general we talked about the writings
yeah I bear I am presented to presenting
to you uh that which the Lord has
presented to me I do not write one
article in the paper expressing merely
my own ideas there what God has opened
before me in Vision the precious rays of
light shining from the throne okay the
precious rays of light shining from the
throne and we're gonna see if these are
precious rays of light and you have to
tell me okay so here she shows this is
the the object in question here the the
line in question if there was one sin
above another which called for the
destruction of the race by the flood it
was the base crime of amalgamation of
man and Beast which defaced the image of
God and cause confusion everywhere
God purpose to destroy by a flood that
powerful long-lived race that had
corrupted their ways before him all
right this is spiritual gifts volume 3
page 64. see it for yourselves okay so
what's the base Crime Guys
amalgamation of man and Beast okay yeah
this is what she says now
um she also says this every species of
animal which God had created were
preserved in the ark the confused
species which God did not create were
the result of amalgamation were
destroyed which were the result of
malformation pardon me were destroyed by
the flood and since the flood there has
been amalgamation of men and beasts as
may be seen in the almost endless
varieties of species of animals and in
certain races of men
did y'all catch that
I'm going slow here okay yeah I'll catch
that this is spiritual gifts volume 3
page 75 you guys can find it okay now
again precious rays of light
from the throne
okay now or from the bookshelf that's
the question
okay
um in the article True Blood race
science and early Adventist amalgamation
Theory Revisited by Ronald Osborne uh
this is in Spectrum magazine and just to
be fair guys I tried to find
um the the Spectrum magazine I don't see
that one often okay so but the Osborne
article is available on Academia
um so you can find that there okay
but this is where it's uh from here it
says in 1867 one year before Smith
published his defense of White's words
on amalgamations we'll get to that guys
okay one year before Tennessee clergyman
Buckner H Payne
published under the pseudonym Ariel the
second edition of his book the second
edition of the book okay the Negro what
is his ethnological status I have not
been able to discover when the first
edition appeared whether before or after
spiritual gifts this is Osborne saying
that uh the quote continues Payne used a
vocabulary of catch it crime and
confusion
very close to whites to explain Noah's
flood God could not tolerate the crime
of amalgamation remember what Ellen
White wrote okay Payne wrote that this
sin of association with beasts that had
produced various races I'm gonna
continue but whereas Uriah Smith argued
in defensive White's prophetic Authority
that Amalgamated blood is no worse than
the blood of any Sinner and that
Christians must labor for the
Improvement of the quote-unquote lower
races Peyton heaped vile abuse on those
working to raise the political and
social standing of African Americans
uh the states of people that favor this
equality this is pain talking God will
exterminate and that Ellipsis is in the
uh um the PDF there he said you cannot
elevate a beast to the level of a son of
God
okay talking about Black Folk there when
placed alongside Payne's racist screed
some might argue Smith's defense of
White's statement on amalgamation thus
represented a significant advance in
racial thinking for the time
for one thing pain does not assume that
animal human amalgamation produced
African-Americans
he assumes that blacks were created
beasts to begin with so that black white
amalgamations were in fact the original
Animal Human amalgamations uh oh
this is Ellen White's uh contemporaries
you're talking about this okay
continuing
Payne's use of the term amalgamation
should dispense once for all with empty
nickel's claim repeated by a number of
Adventist writers since that in mid-19th
Century America the word was not used to
describe animal human combinations it
clearly was we can finish the stream
right here but we're not gonna right
this is precisely why uh White was
immediately understood by both her
critics as well as Smith to be saying
that racial differentiation was the
result of animal human hybridizations
that's on page nine of our um uh
Osborne's article all right you guys can
jump in there if you'd like to or uh do
you have Smith's quote or do you want me
to bring that up right now oh I got it
yeah it's coming up yeah okay so we'll
wait for it then it's just disgusting
and
CNB it wasn't just Kane who was speaking
like this there there were a number of
guys who were literally writing on the
sub-humanity
of of whites the blacks and
blacks rather
the subject management of blacks or
whites and Caucasian races for example
books like negromania what is the what
is the black human or beast and a number
of them yeah were performed the same
idea
and the same idea surrounding
uh black and white interracial marriages
and I'm finding them the segregation Etc
all of these were floating around in
fact Ellen White had these in her
Library as well
so she was drawn from a lot of these uh
books and reproducing their racist
statements and ideologies and claiming
that they were from God
all right
um miles I put um something in the back
chat if you don't mind um checking that
out here
um so Mouse is going to post
um a link to an article from harvard.edu
talking about scientific racism okay
that's a whole thing okay and it's
tendrils still cling to this very day
okay I work Healthcare and there are a
lot of things and assumptions that
happen to be in healthcare that are
based out of scientific racism to this
very day all right so y'all need to be
paying attention to what's going on and
um and just kind of as a as a matter of
fact here
um Serena Williams the world-class
tennis player almost lost her life
um based on some issues that happened
and it's very likely I'm not gonna get
into that tonight but it's very likely
that had to do with her race so we're
not going to get into that right now we
don't have time for it but it's a thing
okay so just uh trust and believe that
for now okay so moving on
so let's get to uh your Iceman's defense
here that's where we were okay so um
whatever and this is published in the
reviewing Herald
um 1866 here as I said yeah classes
just before you go and dismiss defense
let's provide some bad drugs why his
defense was necessary sure go ahead you
had several Adventists
past those things as an evangelists who
actually had left adventism at that time
and the amalgamation issue was one of
the main issues they were constantly at
stating and pushing to the public
as to what makes her false projects so
for example the can write uh smoking
Burton cough who had several of these
respected former sbas who are pushing
this issue out that as proof that she's
a false prophet and who were close
associate of her who were actually
saying that it was confided to them with
Ellen White meant about amalgamation
that God did not create the which
was a racial slang for black people
other Negroes Etc
Etc and so they were saying that you
know the visions of Elohim cannot be
from God
and
how she's racist and how she views black
people
and so as a result of this
uh Uriah Smith was passed by the General
Conference of Seventh-Day Adventists to
actually write the visions of Ellen
White and David and one of the glaring
and most prominent issue was
amalgamation of man and peace and so he
wrote
um these treaties the sending a variety
of things pertaining to Wildlife is
legitimate and he defended what she said
about amalgamation of modern Beast is
actually correct so that is the the sort
of the background Brothers
that eventuated Uriah Smith's defensive
amalgamation
well there you have it folks background
information okay
um here we go back to the slides okay so
this is Uranus defense and again it was
published in the reviewing Herald uh and
you can see the date at the bottom uh
and here says quote uh whatever race of
man we may take Bushmen hot and tots
patagonians or any class of people
however low they may apparently be in
the scale of humanity which we'll talk
about that later their mental capacities
in are in every instance the basis on
which we are to work and which we
determine we determine whether they are
subjects of moral government or not
then what about uh all this to do over
the charge which is in itself false that
the Visions teach that the Negro Is Not
a Human Being what does it amount to it
is simply an effort to create Prejudice
in the minds of the people unworthy
anyone who makes any pretension to being
a Christian or even a gentleman this is
Universe part of his answer anyway to do
to deal with it right so Ellen White was
right and if we look at the Bushmen the
hot and tax and patagonians uh however
low they may be right uh we can still
work with them because they might have
some of Adam's blood that's coming later
okay and just so we're clear when we
talk about these people groups we're
talking about the Bushmen or the sign
people in southern Africa okay they're
actually people not animals
who also live very close to the sons
right
we have the patagonians aka the uh to
the uh to who to well Chase right so
well Chase that's it uh Native South
American people group okay so they're
darker skinned people and if you notice
Allen common you know again they're
darker skin are black people
um again shout out to BK apologist if
you check out his channel
um we had a stream not long ago talking
about Revelation chapter 13 and the
Beast image that comes out of the the
the Earth
in Revelation 13 and that's also based
in racism so you can find that there and
I'm not a CRT practitioner I don't
believe in that I'm not some social
justice Warrior I'm a person that's down
for truth so please check that out um
and so your world view uh can be uh put
up to the test and see what's what okay
um a great controversy you know you know
what that says in there the land was
empty was the land empty find out for
yourself okay
all right so some attempt at cleaning
this up okay some attempts to clean this
up uh first uh this is from the white
estate
what is the general meaning of the word
amalgamation
is it ever used to describe the depraved
Act of cohabitation of man with Beast
right no dictionaries we have ever had
access to not even the exhausted
exhaustive Oxford English Dictionary
indicate that the term has ever been
used to describe this act
there is another Standard English word
that may be properly used to describe
such cohabitation okay the primary usage
of the word amalgamation through long
years have been to describe the fusion
of certain metals and by extension to
the note the fusing of races of men
wait what
did y'all catch that
in the mid 19th century the word was
commonly employed in the United States
to describe the intermarriage of the
White and The Negro race
okay
the Crux of the amalgamation passages is
this amalgamation of man and Beast that
statement could be construed to mean the
amalgamation of man with Beast or
amalgamation of man and of beast at
chemical defense in a construction like
this the preposition of is not
necessarily repeated though it may be
clearly implied just real quick uh how
can something might be clearly implied
yes oxymoronic it's ridiculous okay and
if you notice they're they're destroying
themselves here okay we might speak of
the scattering of man and beasts over
the Earth but we do not therefore mean
that previously man and beasts were
fused on in one mass at one geographical
spot
we simply mean that the scattering of
man over the earth and the scattering of
beasts over the Earth uh though the
original locations of the two groups
might have been on opposite opposite
sides of the Earth in other words the
scattering of man and beasts this is
what they want you to believe that
amalgamation means so animals are over
here someplace human beings are over
here someplace so they're amalgamating
by being scattered and then coming
together
really
how does that Mar the image of God
you know is that a face
total Annihilation
even if it's racism how does a white man
marrying a black woman become such a
base crime a heinous act that Warrior
death total Annihilation again
it still does not compute
it is unbelievable
it's unbelievable and by the way easier
to sing you that you can't hear oh you
brought the mic up okay
um but yeah this is it doesn't make any
sense this defense okay this is an egw
estate by the way so kind of if you know
the egw estate wants you to believe that
the term amalgamation was not used to
denote sexual Union between man and
beasts that's what they said right but
it did refer to the fusion of metals is
Fusion pushing apart or coming together
anybody help me out
of course Fusion of metals and races of
men including intermarriage hello
so if there's intermarriage you think a
man and wife if they're married might
have sex every now and again I don't
know
it's a standard kind of thought
I don't know or or maybe you have to
save yourself because of the you know uh
the the of animal passions and such but
didn't they just saved it yeah yeah
didn't they just say that no dictionary
ever use this word in that way that's
what they said
the same quote
like it's um go let's go back so this is
the I think the white estate there dot
org Legacy issues slash amalgamation
just put amalgamation in there and you
can find it for yourself it's crazy okay
we mean the scattering of man no oh gosh
they're scattering even the Bible option
for the use of the term Fusion that's
like the exact opposite of what Fusion
is Fusion is not a scattering
and for those in the back that don't
that aren't catching what were going on
let's go to a dictionary okay Fusion
okay the process or result of joining
hello two or more things to form a
single entity
oh and look
it says amalgamation for people that
can't read the small print
okay
Fusion is the result of joining two or
more things to form a single entity also
known as amalgamation dummy okay so I'm
gonna stop with the nonsense
again the egw estate wants you to
believe that the term amalgamation was
not used to denote sexual Union between
the man and beast but it did refer to
the fusion of metals and races of men
including intermarriage make it make
sense please
it doesn't say what it what you're
claiming it says even though it does say
what you're claiming it says
[Laughter]
so this is absolutely not this and this
is what your church is telling you okay
like okay fact there's no definition of
amalgamation on the planet that denotes
scattering
there is none it doesn't exist give me a
break man it this should show people how
desperate of an attempt in a defense
this is like
come on man
it's it's terrible okay all right gotta
move on a little bit okay so Ellen
White's contemporaries disagree with the
current defense proposed by the white
estate okay and some folks in her day
had questions about the validity of her
statements as well her day her
contemporaries okay so Spirit of
Prophecy okay this is GV Kilgore
um and he writes in the review and
Herald and um November 28th 1878. Spirit
of Prophecy volume 1 page 78 that's the
um quote we just read was referred to
and ridiculed by a Baptist minister
he said that what sister white said
about amalgamation of man and Beast was
utterly impossible
wait a second
what was the standard defense
from the uh element estate here
that just meant Fusion right
into America which is a scattering right
so you can't intermarry or scatter
or fuse
okay just so so we're clear keeping up
okay so I referred him this is Kilgore
talking I referred him to Johnson's new
encyclopedia Pages 1040 to 10 40 and
1042 that he might learn for the first
time because you don't understand Mrs
White yet you might learn for the first
time if he never knew it before that
quote Allied species are capable as a
rule of pairing and producing Offspring
End quote files how do you produce
offspring
again I am one of these mixed race
Amalgamated species so maybe my my
thinking faculties are not the strongest
but I believe after having a son myself
it's through uh
intercourse
yeah
there you go okay Offspring and that
under the influence of man Mongrel races
hello pay attention Mongrel races
readily arise and are indefinitely
sustained what just exactly what sister
white says
so my friends we have to ask was Sister
white referring to pairing and producing
offspring
Kilgore thinks that
yeah
people have to understand but for almost
90 years
83 years to be exact
ly this was the standard understanding
understands of all adventures in fact
when it was first proposed April 1931 by
George McCready price
that they shift the word by adding the
additional of
so as to not make it look like she was
actually saying man and animals into
Britain it caused the massive controls
in that Adventist Church
that D.E Robinson
he was Ellen White's personal secretary
for years
he stepped up and immediately
immediately shot the argument down
he refuted McCready prices articles
and said it did violence to what Anna
white meant because he personally knew
what Eloise meant being her secretary
and he went through Ella white
literature which he had to say on the
issue and proved that she didn't mean
amalgamation of man and his prefer to
human interbreeding with animals and
brothers and sisters for the next 16
years until
1947 when the issue blew up again no one
dared to try to respond to and refute De
Robinson
he heckled the issue
the entire Adventist Church was settled
on the mother when he refused it
this first reinterpretation of of man
and of peace to make it seem like of man
refers to different types of humans and
of these refer to different types of
beasts he refuted that but then it have
to come back because they were going to
lose credibility in 1947
if they did not embrace the of mind out
of these which have become the standard
SDA interpretation and argumentation
and we'll see why
CMB really quick to support what EJ just
said I'd like to share a quote from a a
primary source oh yeah a primary source
folks
of
we got to flip through here all the way
to the end
I want to actually share two two quotes
here
this is from BF Snook
BF snook and wh uh brinkeroff EJ
mentions this in his book by the way
folks I'll I'll put the link to that in
the description down below
um volume 3 of his book completely blows
the lid off of this claim by the way
with all of the primary sources
so I want to share one of the quotes
here from a book they wrote called the
visions of EG white not of God
this was in 1866
Ellen White wrote this win EJ
1864 when she first made the statement
they defected and left and in 18
1866 responded that was two years later
two years later this is what they write
in their book on page four again you can
look at this book online it's there's a
the PDF is available online just Google
the visions of E.G white not of God BF
snook they say on page for quote
these Visions teach that the Negro race
is not human
this charge they deny but we will let
the reader decide for himself
here is what she says
since the flood there's been an
amalgamation of man and Beast as may be
seen in the almost endless varieties of
species and in certain races of men
spiritual gifts volume 3 page 75 the
quote we looked at
but what are we to understand by certain
races of men
remember this was an an Adventist a
primary source at the time of this being
written
she has not informed us in her writings
but left us to fix the stigma of
amalgamation where me we may see fit but
the interpretation has come to light she
told it to her husband and he made it
known to Elder Ingraham
and he divorced the secret to the writer
the that sister White had seen that God
never made the
um
that's a primary source folks but we're
supposed to go with FD nickel 90 years
removed
over a guy like this who you just have
to say well he was lying okay well
whatever that's a primary source I'm
rolling with the primary source over 90
years removed he says that Ellen White
can confided in James her husband and
James spilled the beans because he
couldn't keep the secret that she said
what it meant was God never made the
another quote
just to show you how the word
amalgamation was used at the time of
Ellen White writing this
Abraham Lincoln
rather popular guy known by quite a few
people in the United States you'd say
what does he say this is from the
collected works of Abraham Lincoln Vol 2
page 406. he said this in 1857
so around Ellen White's time who had
books in her library that used the word
amalgamation very regularly and it
referred to what exactly we're talking
about tonight Abraham Lincoln uses the
uses this word as well in the same
grammatical construction as Ellen White
did
this is him speaking about the political
climate of the day
quote there is a natural disgust in the
minds of nearly all white people to the
idea of the indiscriminate amalgamation
of the white and black races
and judge Douglas evidently is basing
his chief hope upon the chances of being
able to appropriate the benefit of this
disgust to himself if he can
uh by much drumming and repeating fasten
the odium of that idea upon his
adversaries he thinks he can struggle
through the storm he therefore clings to
this hope as a drowning man to the last
plank he makes an occasion for lugging
in well the point is instead of having
to read all this the point is he uses
the phrase amalgamation the same exact
way that Ellen White did because that
was the way it was culturally used at
that time
so when these SDA apologists tell us
that we're clueless critics and we're
not using words the proper way like the
word race they try to say no no by race
and that day it meant class of people it
didn't mean ethnic races well okay the
word amalgamation at that time clearly
meant miscegenation right and that Beast
was a regular term to refer to colored
people so the amalgamation that was
happening that she was talking about was
between white people and colored people
this is going to get a whole lot worse
in just a minute okay so
um again uh Kilgore in his uh uh defense
of Ellen White refers this Baptist
minister to Johnson's new cyclopedia now
when uh BK and I first did this stream
um a couple years ago I was looking all
over the place to try and find it uh
could not find it in time for that that
thing and I still would periodically
look for it but
it has to be what you would consider a
Divine timing if you will you know
Providence that sort of thing look what
I found
uh-huh look at what I found okay
Johnson's new Universal cyclopedia a
scientific and popular treasury of
useful knowledge volume three part two
the very one that Kilgore is referring
to it is available right there for your
viewing pleasure on Google Books
check it out okay so um when uh he is
talking about amalgamation right
kilgorez he is dealing with um this
entry here on page 1040 and 1042 he's
dealing with the entry of hybridization
or hybridity okay so a couple of I'm
just gonna read a few quotes from here
okay
um the treats the issue of dissimilar
kinds hybridity treats the issue of
dissimilar kinds of animals and plants
in or in other words The Offspring The
Offspring
The Offspring of parents which belong
respectively to different varieties or
species
few subjects have been so much
misunderstood or have given rise to so
many superstitions as this
in the olden times and indeed until
quite recently pay attention guys among
the educated as well as among the
ignorant the grossest credulity
prevailed respecting the possibility of
get this Offspring between the most
dissimilar forms hmm let's keep reading
that doesn't sound like cross-breeding
species as possible does it
so let's see what they're talking about
here same article the belief prevailing
that women could become pregnant from
intercourse with beasts
okay laws have been framed condemning to
death the parents who were judged guilty
of the crime of such unnatural Commerce
in 1543 for example a woman in Avignon
France was delivered of a child which
was thought to look like a dog
and this supposed resemblance was
sufficient evidence that the mother had
intercourse with the dog and she was
consequently condemned with her I love
how they said this quadruped Paramore to
diet the stake and was accordingly
executed people legitimately thought
that you could have uh intercourse with
animals and so forth like that and again
when we look at
um uh uh Kilgore and we look at um
um what's his face Uriah Smith's defense
they'll cite um Leviticus chapter 18
against bestiality
right and say that's the reason why God
said so
okay
and people have to realize that this was
before what we call modern science yes
they were saying this because there was
not a lot of scientific data which is
what EJ pointed to earlier that in the
1940s and 1950s there were great strides
in this area which caused the SDA Church
to panic and this got brought back up as
a blip on the radar
facts okay now you have to ask yourself
why would they uh I'm sorry you want to
say something brother
no I was saying right that's correct and
remember to uh even historical equipment
up to that time you you're talking about
Greek mythology was very popular as well
yes and so Greco-Roman mythology with
the various
human animal hybrids like the Minotaur
and all of those pictures of those and
these were prevalent beliefs yeah and
the the the the half horse half man and
all of these things were very prevalent
in the minds of these people mermaids
yeah androgynous people mm-hmm
absolutely and and so people who had
accentuated teachers
they believed were the result of of
humans and animals and to read it
and and so let's again brothers and
sisters don't try to judge this thing
from today's
Advanced scientific knowledge and all of
these kind of stuff these were primitive
people and of course I don't know why
everything she read and
socialized there she hopped on and
concepts of people she attributed divine
inspiration to all of it
was
an FBA believed it was their whole heart
that these were true these were factuals
and they were finding quote-unquote
scientific literature
the science of the date and all of that
to say well this is true and and she she
is true because uh she's agreeing with
science here
but by the time real time got in the
picture a lot of these myths and
theories were being the songs one after
the other that's why she writes
voluminously about the ills and the
ghastly effects of masturbation and all
of these different ideas that because
that's what they foreign
again as we study mon Adventure Science
it's all gone
all right so we have to keep that in
mind
all right so um and we'll keep that in
mind as far as the scientific science is
concerned because uh this is
contemporary stuff and again I invited
everyone to look at that um link that
was provided before to the Harvard
article
um about scientific racism uh if you
have the stomach for it go check it out
you know that includes phrenology
um you know racism in different ways and
stuff like that there to again not a CRT
guy not a social justice guy
um so just you see the shirt it's King
Jesus all day that's where I'm at so I
was just about to say
you're not just using like uh like
cultural Buzz words when you know saying
these things we're talking about like
the real deal thing here folks all right
keep on rolling and what's up Madeline
what's going on this all right so let's
go on here uh What uh what they think
okay why would they think this way okay
so again look at what she said uh since
the flood there's been amalgamation
abandon Beast as may be seen okay so you
can see
the amalgamation because people look a
certain way right and people according
to you know
good weekend injection to to magnify a
frame CMD yeah first she says the flood
came as a result of the amalgamation
right but what are those PCS and those
people who were Amalgamated
and then we see she says now this is
After the flood now
since that time
to the present and so which means there
was not a time that it stopped
up to this point and you can look all
around you
this is happening and then they start to
give tangible examples and people groups
as to who are expressions of this
amalgamation go on bro yeah I'm just
looking uh to Dr Alan and Davis God
bless you man I was looking at Fred
Simmons's quote here uh or his uh
comment said that uh the Angels won't
come into there with us
um if you're as old as I am in SDA if
you went to the movies the Angels didn't
go with you so that's another that's
another stream
let's go let's move on right so uh yeah
so LNG white is trying to fix things out
again going back to the Osborne article
that we saw earlier okay and it might
seem like it's all over the place guys
but this is why we have to kind of do a
shotgun approach so you can see
everything together okay systematic if
you will my friends uh um in 1901 the
review and Herald published together
with a front page article quote unquote
judge not by Ellen White a letter from
from a concerned Adventist asking the
question can Amalgamated Be Blood be
saved wait a minute
can Amalgamated blood be said blood that
was fused
I thought it was I thought it was just
inner marriage
[Laughter]
unbeliever and a Believer has a child
well the child can't be saved because
we're talking about inner marriage right
that's what Ellen White was saying with
her quote unbelievable
the human animal hybrid
made a good grief look at this the
editors now A.T Jones and Uriah Smith
replied that persons with Amalgamated
blood were certainly not Beyond
salvation and further that the
amalgamation spoken of by Sister white
did not violate or invalidate
physiological law
the difficulty that was that science
showed that hybridized creatures
there it is The Offspring uh-oh such as
mules which are the result of sexual
Union between horses and donkeys were
infertile and could not perpetuate their
species however they continued quote
might it not uh be that sufficient
result of bestiality would appear as to
have a trace of amalgamation
results of bestiality and you guys don't
have to be gross but you know what that
is okay
um without destroying the power of
generation
the amalgamation spoken of by white is
seen in what is called certain races of
men
this shows that deterioration was not
recognized to such a degree as to
eliminate the human and transform any
such offering Offspring into beasts
oh my
in so many words the flagship Journal of
the Adventist Church at the turn of the
century was simply upholding the
church's long-held understanding based
upon white statements and Smith's
vigorous if not authoritative
interpretation and defense of them
nearly four decades earlier
put that in your pipe and smoke it
the Assurance offered to concerned
members in 1901 as he in I'm sorry is in
the 1960s one that white spoke
authoritatively not only on a religious
but also scientific matters and two that
Amalgamated persons might still qualify
as human beings and subjects of
philanthropic concern
so long as they had at least some of
Adam's blood in their veins regardless
of whether or not that blood had been
tainted in the ancient past with the
blood of animals so my friends how in
the world
do you get the blood of animals inside
the blood of humans if amalgamation does
not mean amalgamation yikes
I told you I was gonna get worse
okay
quoting even done yet here we go but the
fact that some races were degraded or
quote unquote lower than others as white
had eluded and as Smith had plainly
declared was still taken as quotes as
self-evident by most Adventists as it
was by most Americans and Europeans of
their day
the hat and tots or Southern African of
south southern Africa pardon me who
Smith had cited as quintessential
examples of Amalgamated beings were the
subjects of some particularly
Sensational commentary in the reviewing
Herald throughout the 19th century now
what
foreign
real quick real quick just on this folks
I want you to remember do not lose this
from your focus because they're the
Adventist Church is going to try and do
the sideshow the circus over on the side
no no look over here look over here
this is being attributed to God
God said this through Ellen White that's
why the thumbnail of this video has the
little added speech bubble on there no
God made me say it because that's the
pivot that they take
well no like WC Willie white her son
tried to to say in spiritual gifts and
somewhere in the page 300s 323 or
something like that he tries to make the
claim well well God guided her in um
what she needed to remove and change and
when to take something out and when to
add something in
oh it's God's fault she's saying these
things
this is being pinned on God it's not
just Ellen White saying this
um
oh boy it's bad
this is not good
horrendous okay so let's look at some
relatively recent examples of
Sensational commentary of Amalgamated
species um again if you're as old as me
um you might remember a couple of things
that you might have seen in the grocery
checkout counter so one of which is
National Enquirer other one weekly world
news Okay so
a dolphin grows human arms okay so uh
yeah okay
things like this okay half man half dog
baffles doctors
okay
a bat child escapes
okay why am I including stuff like this
this is essentially what people were
thinking was happening
in her day okay and I'm gonna prove it
here in just a second again okay back to
Johnson's encyclopedia okay
same entry although quote although such
beliefs have now been driven to more
obscure quarters they are by no means
extinct and indeed are still very
prevalent in fact extravagant accounts
of animals of again Mongrel origin are
frequently published in the daily and
weekly newspapers hello
okay it may be therefore and be
advisable to enter into some detail in
advance to deny the truth of most of the
reports okay
sometimes says it reminds you the
X-Files yeah exactly
right under the general uh designation
of hybrids are embraced all forms all
those forms whose parents parents
parents belong to different varieties or
species whether The Offspring is fertile
or not the word hybrid is thus
essentially similar in its meaning to
the Anglo-Saxon term Mongrel okay
do you remember
when that word was used previously
okay
continuing French writers have
classified the forms embraced in the
general term three categories I'm sorry
that was the uh the way it uh pulled up
when I um did it in the uh PDF here
sorry guys all right so hybrids mules
and metis okay metis uh metis hybrids
meals okay
um metis
um originally specifically excuse me
specially employed to designate The
Offspring of an Indian Mother by a white
father well that was two different races
of humans
and has been extended as a generic term
to humans and plants of mixed origin I.E
The Offspring of two races or varieties
of the same species okay so there's no
hiding from this guys
thank you
okay
last couple quotes from that uh
encyclopedia here repeated in prolonged
critical observations and experiments
have amply demonstrated that uh I.E uh
belonging to uh decidedly different
families that excuse me
that fruitful Union there you go it's
impossible between animals or plants or
of widely different species such as only
possible within comparatively narrow
although uncertain limits we may
therefore at once dismiss as utterly
Unworthy of belief the many reports of
Offspring from such forms that have been
published by even accredited writers of
natural history and past and pastimes
such examples as the alleged case of
hybrids between a hen and a duck an
opossum and a cat a boar and a camel an
otter and a rabbit an otter and a sheep
an iron a cat a raccoon in a cat and
especially women and apes dogs or other
animals y'all see what's happening here
so when they say
no no no she's talking about because
this is where they added the word of
there in in Ellen's quote to say no no
no it's talking about amalgamation of
humans and then there was amalgamation
of beasts it wasn't the two things
together right no no no no look here
folks women and apes
foreign
you saw that lady in France was uh was
killed in the 1500s right
because her baby look kind of dogish
this is terrible okay
and remember this too when they want to
use the argument oh no no when she said
races of men you need to use the
definitions of that day that's what this
is now here you are
how much how much more in that day can
you get
and and again to give to give an example
of races of men
and Uriah Smith's 1868 defense of these
statements
he highlighted the wild Bushmen of
Africa
some tribes of the heart and thoughts
and perhaps the bigger Indians
as a mild stated races of men that she
was referring to examples of imagination
right here fellas
foreign
I'm going to start a little bit earlier
he says now we have ever supposed that
anybody that was called a man was
considered a human being the vision
speaks of all these classes as races of
men yet in the face of this plain
declaration they foolishly assert that
the Visions teach that some men are not
human beings but does anyone deny the
general statement contained in the
extract given above
they do not
if they did they could easily be
silenced by a reference to such cases as
the wild Bushmen of Africa some tribes
of the hottentots and perhaps the Digger
Indians of our own country yes he says
does anyone deny the general sentiment
and statement that the two lines that
the line between animal and human has
been blurred by such people like the
African Bushmen the hottentots and the
Digger Indians
that's how he understood this he was a
contemporary of Ellen White he knew the
whites he was one he was the SDA
Church's like first theologian
that's how he understood what she was
saying
and it shall not be argued that and my
wife was ignorant of his defense
because again the General Conference of
SD at that time
we're more than happy
to endorse his defense
to publish it to urge people to buy his
paper
and even the whites themselves
for camp meeting that year
they took and sold 2 000 copies
of Smith's book defending Anna white
amalgamation and given the examples that
he gave that she is right it is
scientifically factual and she's a true
prophet
here's the receipts folks for what EJ
just said before Smith's quotes were
published
the month before his statements were
published in July
the month before
June June 12 1866
this is what was published at the end of
the review and Herald article that day
the official organ of the SDA Church
what was resolved
that we the members of the general and
Michigan State Conference
fellas what role does the general
conference play in the SDA Church
what did Ellen White it's the highest uh
was it um assembly
when the general conference is in
session it is the highest governing body
with the most Authority on Earth and
your own personal opinions depending on
the decisions they make must be set
aside
the general conference and the Michigan
State conference have read a portion of
the manuscript red which has been
prepared by Brother Uriah Smith this is
where that quote from Erasmus is coming
from that's the paper they're
referencing in answer to certain
objections recently brought against the
visions of sister white we do buy Here
express our hearty approval of the same
another thing that's been resolved that
we tender our thanks to brother Smith
for his able defense of the Visions
against the attacks of their opponents
so who was that in in this in 66 we just
looked at BF snook earlier what was BF
making the charge against what was the
objection that he was making
she's saying that wasn't made by
God
in response to that
resolved that we tender our thanks to
brother Smith for his able defense of
the Visions against the attacks of their
opponents
we would further state that in preparing
these answers we have had no
consultation whatever with sister white
now get this folks
we've had no consultation with whatever
with sister white nor received any
suggestion or explanation from her on
any point we take the Visions as they
are published
and base our explanation of any apparent
discrepancy on the language as it stands
ah
ah so there we have it this confession
completely demolishes the modern
arguments
of Adventist apologies Uriah Smith and
the general office leaders and pastors
read Ellen White statements as they are
and concluded that she indeed meant that
humans interbred with animals and
certain races of men were produced as we
saw Smith provided some examples of
dark-skinned people who were created due
to this amalgamation it's a wrap it's
over
and it's the same thing we do today
we take the Visions as they are we
reason in the language and they are
written and we understand and come to
the conclusion that they intend to
contain
so it is not us who are virtual and
destroying and being the coolest critics
who who are perhaps having Aphasia don't
know what words mean anymore it is the
FDA apologist right who from the 1940s
for experiencing and to save the face of
the Prophet is in the church
who had to reinterpret
and with the insertion of McCready price
of 1931 with the little of to try to
make it look like she is saying a
different thing to save themselves today
it is then who are doing that
butchering person who are doing violence
to the tests and who are not taking her
as she reads in order to save themselves
it's not us who's doing that we are
doing exactly what the general
conference did and came to the
conclusion that they did an Loy of
course
they were so elated with along with the
husband and the others with Smith
defense that they were more than happy
to sell two
two thousand copies of Smith's defense
of her statements
yeah and in my video I mentioned that
real quick CMB I mentioned that in the
video that I uploaded a couple weeks ago
about well Juneteenth advertisement
racism and James White comments on that
in the August 25th 18.
uh I don't 1880 I don't remember exactly
what it is but it the quote is there in
that video where he says he read over
the entirety of the manuscript right and
then him and Ellen went and sold copies
of of White's book it's super long the
title it's like the visions of Ellen G
white and something something something
that Uriah Smith wrote that made its way
into this review and Herald article they
sold 2 000 copies of this book and James
said he read the manuscript and he was
happy to go out and do so so yeah this
idea that oh Ellen never endorsed his
words
oh yeah right she just went and sold 2
000 books which at that time right that
was a lot they didn't have Amazon right
and in person you know what I mean so
you get the celebrity culture that's
there anyway you know James and Ellen
White all the Visionary you know I can
buy a book I can touch I can kiss her
hand I can you know I can touch the hand
that the The Inspired pen uh sits in you
know come on guys you know I mean like
this is this is really it's terrible
situation and we're not trying to make
light of this it is what it is okay
it is what it is let's let's finish this
up real quick guys all right um so let
me get over here again
um so yeah the one of the main problems
again with kilgore's citation of Johnson
encyclopedia so that's why I'm going
back to this again and we're gonna just
bury this right here okay
um
Allied species can quote procreate
that's what he said okay Allied species
can procreate and that was his defense
against that Baptist Minister now here's
the problem
among invertebrates there are less known
and determined cases but hybrids have
been obtained between uh different
species of bees butterflies Etc and many
intermediate forms found in the state of
nature have been supposed to be hybrids
the results thus far obtained from all
these various departments maybe
summarized as follows one Allied species
are capable as a rule of pairing and
producing Offspring and this capability
is indefinite ratio to the degree of
their likeness okay did you catch what
the problem is this is among
invertebrates
are you seeing this
okay so dum dum couldn't read very well
right and was just like many people to
this day looking for confirmation bias
okay so if you are not uh uh to uh well
all of us are online right now so
getting your Google search bar getting
your Bing or whatever you like to use
and look up what the term confirmation
bias means okay
and this is what you'll see
okay
so white jesus is concerned here all
right let's go from here all right quick
recap of the facts that we've looked at
so far
Johnson's new encyclopedia Pages 10 40
10 42 does not agree with kilgore's
defense of Ellen White's statements
about amalgamation
this encyclopedia enter entry uh it
demonstrates the idea of hybrid dog
people and others like it are
Fabrications in scientific
impossibilities but Ellen does not
realize this
okay
kilgore's defense fails
FD Nichols defense fails the egw estate
offense fails um what's the other guy
McCready price his fails and Illinois is
teaching here is a 100 false
yes
yeah and I want to address this guy
really quick here in the comments this
Mark Anthony he is a regular here that
likes to costume in the comment section
he says does anyone here have a PhD in
biology no Mark we don't need a PhD in
biology just like the GC session didn't
need to have a PhD in biology to
understand what she was saying either
all right CMB continue
thank you
oh gosh I was going to say something
about third grade education but I'm
going to stop all right Ellen White was
influenced by at current events and
plagiarized
um an open racist position to posit
amalgamation between man and Beast was
possible
you saw that right
Ellen White meant exactly what she said
Ellen White attributed these horrific
things to God in contradiction to the
scriptures and these Wicked statements
influence how SDA ism is practiced to
this very day SDA apologists often say
things like Ellen White was a champion
for the rights of black Americans and
those who were disenfranchised she
taught equality between the races
did you
no one is capable of clearly defining
the proper position of the colored
people testimonies volume nine
page 213
paragraph four
nobody
is capable of clearly defining the
proper position of the colored people
I didn't know we had to have those
the colored people should not urge that
they be placed on an equality with the
white people oh there you go right the
relation of the two races has been a
matter hard to deal with and I fear it
will ever remain a most perplexing
problem
ever
so far as possible everything that would
stir up the race Prejudice of the white
people should be avoided there is danger
of closing the door that our white
laborers will not be able to work in
some places in the South it's from the
southern uh work and also in testimony
share I know that if we attempt to meet
the ideals and preferences of some of
the colored people we shall find our way
black completely
the work of proclaiming the truth for
this time is not to be hindered by an
effort to adjust the position of the
Negro race and mind you this is in uh
like when the days of the um the was the
morning start that's going down the
Mississippi River and all this right
um should we attempt to do this we
should find that barriers like mountains
would be raised to hinder the work that
God desires to have done okay so yes
this was in the um uh uh at Bellum South
there okay
um and uh or maybe yeah so around the
time the war maybe before the uh the
Civil War or something like that you
know um but the point is that they were
trying to get down there
um and preach their message
we're gonna see a couple things in a few
minutes here one thing on that real
quick just because there's a common
defense that they try to give to this to
say no no no she wasn't talking about
um that as like human beings they're not
equal it's just that right now with the
way that the political climate is they
shouldn't go against the the way that
the law is because it will hinder the
way for us to make progress
folks this is coming from God abolition
was headed and spearheaded by Christians
the the government does not determine
what God then says is right and wrong
there are do we have a track record in
scripture of God ever oh I don't know
having people stand up against corrupt
governments
right it was God's counsel no no we
don't want to stir anything up yeah
because God doesn't have a Tracker to
ever stirring anything up politically
right that's just a silly defense that's
just a silly defense
with all of her statements
on on top of that Miles
this argument about the time and the
dangers you you have the Quakers the
Quakers had no profit
the Quakers did not have the clout that
the sdas had yet they stood squarely
Against Racism and segregation
and I think in the 1940s they won a
Nobel Peace Prize for it mm-hmm
and and so so so don't don't even bring
up that silly argument
about just you know for peace sake I
mean this was dehumanizing
it was this was very dehumanizing it was
cowardice
an Adventists had racist ideologies and
Views about blacks simply because of
these these humanized statements that
analyze made about black people yes she
self-contradictory made them nice pretty
Skillets about blacks I I document all
of that in volume three
where she died for the equality and and
and their humanity and and
um
what would you call it now reparations
and those kind of things
but all of those good three statements
were based on her altruism
that now she's able to benefit from
these people and her church can benefit
from them
but after making those statements
the lack of part of her work in Ministry
is these sort of a racist statement that
she makes about black people even so far
as saying that in heaven segregation and
racism will stop because blacks are
going to be white like Jesus oh yeah
that's coming hello
it is not true it is not from God
facts
yeah what these brothers were just
talking about is right here we're
demanded by custom or we're greater uh
efficiencies to be gained let the white
Believers in the color Believers
assemble in separate places of worship
again if it's by the law well we
shouldn't break the law well how quick
okay
folks
in Galatians 3 sorry CNB I'm I'm gonna
I'm gonna say something right on top of
it yeah go ahead
folks you had the exact opposite of this
going on in the early church
when you read Galatians 3 you need to
understand
when it says scythian Barbarian this is
not just like a caveman most people when
they hear the word barbarian they think
like a caveman that's not what's being
said there
there were racial tensions at that time
as well
did Paul say well because there's
political tensions around this right now
or cultural tensions we should separate
our assemblies and not worship together
noodle on that yeah no and and and to go
further right I believe it was Galatians
also where um Paul uh chastised Peter
for um for for for not wanting to uh to
act differently um between when when the
judaizers came right Paul says to his
face
right
you know this is this is ridiculous
right okay Mark Anthony whatever
whatever you want so you missed all the
rest of the stream for the last hour and
47 minutes bro okay whatever right so I
mean feel free anywho so this is kind of
one of those things that you have to
recognize that um being in the presence
of Gentiles and eating with Gentiles um
likely eating their Foods right against
uh the the food loss the dietary laws um
of the Torah right uh these men um you
know when Peter when the judaizers Come
Peter wants to act all high and mighty
right and now being um a respecter of
persons if you will right if Paul was
stands into his face you can find that
in in the book right so
again this precious race of light from
the throne right so this is what you
have to ask and this is the answer is no
listen I don't know what it is but it
ain't light from the throne okay no one
is clearly capable of defining the
proper position of the Color Race she
says meanwhile the scripture says this
God says let us make man in our image
according to our likeness they will rule
the fish to Sea the birds of the sky the
livestock all the earth and the
creatures that crawl on the earth so God
created man in his own image he created
him in the image of God he created them
male and female God blessed them and God
said to them that's the human beings he
just created be fruitful multiply fill
the Earth and subdue it let's skip over
to acts 17. what does this say then Paul
stood in the middle of the areopagus
okay and said men of Athens I see that
you are extremely religious in every
respect for as it wasn't uh excuse me as
I was passing through and observing the
objects of your worship I even found an
altar from which uh on which is
inscribed to an unknown God
therefore what you Worship in ignorance
this I Proclaim to you catch it
The God Who made the world and
everything in it just like we read in
Genesis chapter uh uh one there okay uh
he is the Lord of Heaven and Earth and
does not live in shrines made by hands
neither is he served by human hands as
though he needed anything since he
himself gives everyone life and breath
and all things from one man he has made
every nationality
to live over the whole earth and has
determined their appointed times and the
boundaries of where they live he did
this so that they might seek God and
perhaps reach out and find him though he
is not far from each one of us
Ellen White can't figure out the proper
position of the colored people and I'm
here to tell you what the scripture says
that everybody that draws breath that is
an image bearer of God that's everybody
on the planet uh is of one blood
there is one race the human race
no amalgamation
no man and Beast no image of God being
defiled because of being unequally yoked
we have Jason here in the comments he's
now commenting saying that we're not
being fair with Ellen White okay Jason
okay
there's an objection
to the marriage of the white race with
the black all should consider that they
have no right to entail upon their
offspring that which will place them at
a disadvantage they have no right to
give them as a Birthright a condition
which would subject them to a life of
humiliation the children of these mixed
marriages have a feeling of bitterness
towards the parent who have given the
it's funny how Ellen can know what every
kid uh from a quote unquote mixed
marriage can can feel right crazy I have
a feeling of the bitterness toward the
parent who have given them this lifelong
inheritance for the re for this reason
if there were no other there should be
no intermarriage between the right bite
and the color races okay
I can read it okay again the problem
with this idea of mixed marriages is
that it ignores what this says in Acts
17 and amongst other places God has
created all human beings there's no
mixed marriages
okay we're all one word we're all one
people
and not just that but the excuse that oh
it was just for that time no folks the
point is God did not say this
that's God did not say oh well because
Antebellum slavery's going on I'm
beholden now to this political climate
that's going on in 19th century America
no no that's the point this is not
coming from God and Ellen White claimed
that she never wrote a sentence of
heresy that it was God speaking through
clay it wasn't merely her own opinion
and to go against the things that she
wrote was to insult the spirit of God
give me a break
laughs
you have no license from God to exclude
the colored people from places of
worship oh that's nice
treat them as Christ property which they
are that's nice too just as much as
yourselves yes they should hold
membership in the church with the white
brethren that's nice every effort should
be made to wipe out the terrible wrong
slavery which has been done done them at
the same time we must not carry things
to extremes and run into fanaticism on
this question some would think it would
be right to throw down every partition
wall and intermarry with the colored
people but this is not the right thing
to teach or practice Southern work page
15. yes no no we shouldn't throw down
every partition wall let's keep some of
them up
foreign
just a couple
my friends uh in Mark okay God bless you
man
as you see in the South uh boy bless
your heart
all right okay so um we can get into
that stuff like worship Styles and
whatever the case is at the moment but
um there's a couple things that we can
look at uh from here but you get the
idea right so the whole point guys that
we're talking about is amalgamation the
idea before we get off into the rest of
it here
um the idea is that the thought of the
day
was that black folk and any quote
unquote colored person which means
anyone who hasn't white European right
um was the result of amalgamation
between Mana Beast that was the
Zeitgeist of the day that was the
thought process many people thought that
um the idea of subhuman species was
around
um look it up okay
um the idea of the curse of ham was
running rampant
um if you don't know what that is please
check that out it's terrible
um the idea of and and it pervades to
this day right
um so you have
uh like a white supremacist Cults cult
groups like um the Christian identity
movement and all uh some other things
like that that are pseudo-christian um
they're not real Christian
um obviously organizations but the
pseudo-christian organizations
um and they believe and teach the curse
of hand they believe that um Jews over
in Israel
um are not Jews right
um they're not human beings okay they
believe
um all kinds of stuff like that and same
thing with
um certain camps of Hebrew Israelites
believe that
um that white people are not uh God's
children okay they believe all kinds of
stuff and so there's they're a real real
world implications of this okay
um and if you hold to these bad ideas
and bad doctrines
um what can happen is you'll have
comments like Mr Marc Anthony you can't
keep stop talking right now and he's
you're not saying anything that has any
kind of sense my friend you know um so
this is a problem in where you hold to
certain viewpoints and Ellen can't be
wrong
even if it violates the law of God
even if it violates the laws of logic
even if it violates
um you know laws of science a lot of
science right all of that you know
um so yeah take from that what you will
you know I want to respond to a comment
here really quick because we have Jason
in chat and he said I would love to hear
how you all would have counseled people
in the 1800s Jason you're still not
getting it my friend
this isn't just Ellen White counseling
people
this is coming from God
precious I don't know I don't know how
how to say any other way my man
you need to drop this you need to drop
this that's the reality
that's what it was about they are hawks
who's whose hearts are impervious to the
truths for the facts of History
of context the scripture and
they have too much to lose to accept
that they are wrong on an issue when
they are following a false prophet and
therefore repentance
my counsel Jason I would like to thank
my heart right now is saying that you
know I don't know I'm not in the
situation so obviously I can't speak to
to not being there but I would like to
think my disposition well I mean I'm a
guy who goes out to abortion Mills and
seeks to evangelize those at the
abortion Mill
and walk with them and do Street
evangelism Etc my heart's in a place
where I would like to think that I would
have been on the abolition side you know
because there were people at that time
who were abolitionists Christians
this idea that oh well Ellen White was
just no she's claiming to speak on
behalf of God you're claiming to be
God's last day Church you're the
principium of Truth don't give me that
don't give me that nonsense that like
well you're no better than she is no no
that's not gonna pass off for for
blaming this on God all right
yeah right same same so let's let's
answer the question though um what what
would we have counseled you know um well
if I was alive in the 1800s in the
United States of America I'd probably be
a slave okay so I would want to be free
okay that's kind of that's where I stand
on that situation okay
um but the the answer to your question
is very simple what would you counsel
the people of the 1800s get saved how
about that
you know
submit your heart to the Lord and and
read your scriptures
right
submit your heart to the Lord and let
him melt racism from everybody's heart
that's what I would counsel people to do
because there was no
um no no good science back then people
were just winging it phrenology really
I'm gonna measure skull sizes and see um
who's who's who's uh whose head shapes
would promote um or or denote uh uh
intelligence
you're going to look at people's nose
shapes and lip shapes to tell who who's
who's right or who's more ape-like or
less ape-like people's butt shapes come
on seriously
hold on one second real quick and and so
those kinds of things there right if we
look at those scriptures the plain
reading of the text though that we just
put up there between Genesis uh chapter
one uh verse 26 26 28 whatever I just
read there and then uh Acts chapter 17
you it doesn't take a rocket scientist
to say you know what all human beings
are God's people
all of us need to be uh to submit Our
Lives to Christ
period it doesn't take a rocket
scientist to say that so yes you know
you can look at it from an outsider's
perspective now we can look at it from
21st century uh lens and see all kinds
of stuff there but no matter what
whether it was legal or not there was no
point in time where Channel safely was
right
the scriptures
denounce selling people and kidnapping
people okay and stealing
okay that was punishable by Death
okay so you need to figure you need to
really really take a a an honest look at
this thing we've been talking at this
for almost two hours now okay you can't
sit up here and talk about contests bro
you can't
when he says
he is supposed to be one of the lead and
ask the apologists uh today but the Lord
uh the official official yes I've been
defender on you but as you listen to
these guys they are nothing but you know
maybe
who need a the Masters would experience
you need to hear the gospel of course
and be constantly okay
um when he says here real quick he says
here wisdom comes from God why is it
hard to see that what she said was to
preserve life again Jason do you not
understand that real people
AJ's already mentioned one group the
Quakers who literally preserved life
literally by going against what your
Prophet has said was God's wisdom
no no no just leave them where they're
at
just leave them where they're at that'll
preserve life don't cause a stir because
we want to make sure we can spread this
Adventist poison all over the world and
we don't want to cause any feathers to
be ruffled so we'll just go with the
flow we'll just go with whatever the
times are so that we can have an inlet
to then whenever it's convenient get our
message out there it's not about
preserving life don't give me this
nonsense that is about preserving life
that's not true is it is it really
preserving life when when when when
a white man off was being treated better
than a black man
when when black babies were gigabits is
that really preserving life
blacks have no rights
they're brutalized they're murdered at
the whim of a white person
is the preserving life
telling them that
their value on their worth and and
issues about them just have it's complex
can't be understood and just leasing as
they are
have other than translated from from one
place to the other these precarious
Journeys practically exciting on ships
based on these ideologies I'm working
into death in a field
where the average lifespan is about 30
to 40 Years of ruling labor is that the
preservation of life
is that even life
come on man I I let me not get get
emotional around it but again it goes to
show that these people are hot
they are hacks who who are so overtaken
by these other ideology that whatever it
takes
they must defend these false prophets
and whatever
garbage that is viewed out of their
mouths and it is unfortunate
very unfortunate
ah man um and and again the whole point
is not only does this come from God
allegedly from Illinois okay
um the point is that if you view the
scriptures as is human beings or human
beings
if we looked at that and we actually
lived by that in the 1800s there would
be no concern about inner marriage
okay so you wouldn't be putting your
life at risk for marrying somebody
because they looked different from you
or they're from a different country or
have different culture or whatever the
case is do you understand
that that's the point so I'm I'm trying
like I said there's no reason to get
riled up and stuff like that there you
know about this this is just simple
simple logic if you if we looked at what
the council would be let's read the
scripture as is okay there's not gonna
be a problem
okay meanwhile we have Ellen right here
no I did not say blacks are hybrids chat
so like good please if you didn't watch
the show
um what you can do since you're watching
on YouTube right
um just hit the back button just rewind
it the beginning
you do that right
watch and see what the arguments we're
making please okay so uh further further
I'm not being facetious I'm a little
frustrated right now it's been two hours
and I'm tired so here we go so otherwise
says quote uh you are the children of
God and she's addressing a group of
black folks in Vicksburg
um here
um you are the children of God he has
adopted you and he he desires you to
form characters here that will give you
entrance into the Heavenly family
um remembering this you'll be able to
Bear the trials which you meet here
in heaven there will be no color line
for all will be as white as Christ
himself
let us thank God that we can be members
of the Royal Family
no no no C and B she's not talking about
race here she's just saying that we'll
all have a glow Like Jesus Does it's
like a white light glow oh yeah a new
character will be white like spotless
right
against conceptually
she she's talking to a newly formed
Adventist Church here in Pittsburgh
these people when you look at the
historical context on directors were
being slaughtered yes they were being
brutalized again she mentions of the
trials they were bearing they were being
persecuted segregated dehumanized and
the worst things were happening to them
she came there to preach a message to
encourage them
to endure their trials and burdens
and in the midst of our encouragement
she sought to let them know that these
conditions they are currently facing
here
will not be
in heaven because they are going to have
white skin like Jesus and therefore
there'll be no occasion for the racism
they're experience and no occasion for
the segregation no occasion for that
persecution that is what is happening
and when you look at Moi expenses and
use of color line imperations and again
I've gone through all of this at London
volume three she is talking about
segregation she's talking about literal
skin colors so no she's not talking
symbolically here about character and
Global one and this and that is the
other she's talking to a group of people
who are being
um
emaciated destroyed emasculated lynched
and the whole nine yards because of this
skin color
they have embraced the Adventist faith
and still experience in all of these
things because of their skin color
so she thought to bully them by letting
them know in heaven these conditions
will change because your skin color will
change that is what it is historically
going on there and notice Jason's
comment here again completely misses the
point you show that quote but not the
quote where she says whites and blacks
will be in heaven Jason we never said
that she said blacks won't be in heaven
we literally just said the opposite
they'll be there but they'll be as white
as Jesus this is another perfect example
for you to see folks they're not able to
actually deal with what's being said
they have to just throw out the only
defense that they have
and make these wildest assertations and
whatnot when we just said the opposite
no they'll be there but they'll be as
white as Jesus and yes she says in
heaven there'll be no color line
if she's not talking about race why even
say there'll be no color line
oh my goodness and yeah one more thing
too can you put that back on there it
was too late um okay there you go yeah
so okay so we have this quote here
um where you don't show the quote
um where she says whites and blacks will
be in heaven right so not only are you
saying that on one hand whites and
blacks will be in heaven but on the
other hand the blacks will be as white
as Christ himself how can you tell the
difference of Who's Who
right how can you tell how can you tell
the difference of who if if the black
people are going to be white how can you
tell who's gonna be white okay or who's
black or whatever the case is or which
uh Nation tribe Kindred tugging people
and all that stuff from Revelation you
know um this is the kind of nonsense
that we're seeing here every single time
that we talk right and and the the funny
thing is we're talking about um we
recused earlier of not um uh not not
paying attention to the the context of
the times that this was put up you know
I'm not paying attention to the um uh
the the the the Zeitgeist to the day all
this kind of stuff right well here's the
thing the term color line when it was
used in the mid 1800s to 1900s or
whatever the case was only had one real
Meme and it was dealing with a race
matter of fact into the 1900s if you all
don't know who Ruby Bridges is you need
to look her up
okay in the lifetime I'm not gonna tell
you all my sister is but in the lifetime
of my family members okay
my parents and others who uh uh just you
know in their lifetime
1960s right Ruby Bridges six-year-old
girl had to be escorted to elementary
school
with the U.S national guard
or the State National Park
okay the Army had to escort a girl to
school in some of your lifetime as
you're listening to this uh right now
some of you are old enough to know this
or remember this
okay
so I don't want to hear anything about
that
like at all
okay y'all want to act a certain way you
want to act like we don't know what
we're talking about
um context you know you're misquoting
you haven't read anything in context and
we have been on here for two hours and I
read a huge entry
from the encyclopedia that killed
gorsites
as a defense and he didn't read it
correctly
and you can see it ad nausea this is
nonsense guys it's it's it's it's
laughable that this is what you have to
boil down to
either this came from God or it didn't
that's what she said so you have to
decide
okay
I'm not sure it did not come from
thanks okay all right okay so again
um this is my school here uh remarks
were made by J.E white as the necessity
of establishing an industrial training
school with an easy reach of Nashville
he stated that such schools were
contemplated in the instruction we had
received in the testimonies and that
such institutions were very valuable in
bringing young men and women into proper
training which would give them the best
opportunities to receive the truths of
God's word
he stated that in the works of the
Huntsville school that's Oakwood many
such young men and women were received
and that 9 out of ten were brought who
were brought under these proper
influences
received the truth
and became firm in it before they
finished their course of instruction
more than this many of them consecrated
their lives to missionary work among
their own people
that's the point of why Oakwood is
established it's not because she was
some uh you know um altruistic person
who just wanted to see people saved and
so forth no no there was work to be done
and they couldn't get in by themselves
yeah go ahead
I was saying it wasn't about inclusion
it was about exclusion correct
all right I want to comment at Jason
here again who's again going crazy in
the comment section you're defining
these terms with modern definitions
Jason you need to hit the rewind button
buddy
you need to hit the rewind button
and you don't need to use that argument
because you tried to argue with me
that no no no you need to use the
definitions of that day when it came to
races of men yet you yourself were not
using the definition of that day which
we spent about 45 minutes on for the
word amalgamation
so if you want to play that game buddy
go back and look at the definition of
amalgamation from back then and get back
to us
okay
foreign
I'm gonna I'm gonna read a couple of
things uh
the term color line was originally used
as a reference to the racial segregation
that existed in the United States after
the abolition of slavery
an article by Frederick Douglass that
was called the color line was published
in the North American review in 1881 the
phrase gained famed after uh w-e-b Du
Bois and so forth and so on okay uh
repeated use in the book The 1903 book
The Souls of Black Folk okay again all
of these things are related to Ellen
White's time I'm going to go further
here uh library of congress.gov
drawing the color line
1860s to 1890s Baseball Americans began
playing baseball
and talks about black folks and white
folks not being able to play together
because there was a color line I'm just
reading stuff off here University of
Washington just Google color line 1800s
reading along the color line NAACP
reports from Black America in 1960 and
1917. right
um in its early years the crisis the ND
and double acp's monthly magazine edited
by W.E.B Du Bois uh sought to
um I'm sorry
oops sought to
um
where's that I lost my page here
sorry guys I'm so I lost my picture but
anyway that's the point okay
um black Ohio and the color line okay
as a brilliant examination of race
relations it's a jstor article here
drawing the color line in by 1800 10 to
15 million blacks have been transported
and slated to the Americas okay tell me
how this doesn't have to do anything
with race again please
he lost the plot bro he's now saying as
you see it was all about segregation and
its meaning right Jason so it had to do
with race
Jason you've lost the plot my man you've
lost the plot the whole thing you were
arguing initially was that color line
doesn't have to do with race now you're
admitting it does have to do with race
but oh it was segregation my man I'm out
of the Deception come out of the
deception man
yeah I think we're gonna I think I think
we've killed horse here but
we talked about Regional conferences
before
um you guys know what that is right
yeah the black Dr Davis was talking
about that in the comments earlier
saying that uh
um they still have black and white
conferences mm-hmm sure enough right
um and we talked about that on the um
the stream I did with the DK apologist
so please go check out his chat Channel
um it's called The Hidden race doctrine
of the SDA
um and we talk about Regional
conferences and how those came to be
there's a tragic story of Mrs Lucy
Bayard
um it is no joke it's terrible situation
again along the color line uh she uh was
denied um entrance and treatment at a
local hospital
um in the uh 1940s uh in Washington DC
and unfortunately she passed away about
three weeks after the whole incident
there
um but again this is real history okay
this is recent history and again why are
we talking about this because it comes
Downstream of these comments and these
ideas about amalgamation
okay that's the whole point we can do
this all day for weeks if we wanted to
okay there's no need for it at this
point
this thing is indefensible
it's unbiblical it's ungodly and it's
terrible
like I don't know what else you need
what needs to be said at this point
I mean we didn't even look at all the
quotes tonight if if I may just give a
brief synopsis of why they had to change
the meaning and understanding of
amalgamation
and so by the 1940s again the science
was very clear that
there cannot be any sort of interbreed
between
man and Beast
now there's a difference gentleman by
the name of God shigley in 1982
he wrote an extensive paper entitled
amalgamation of man and peace what did
Ella white mean
and it gives a solid
history of that too and and in the 1940s
why Adventists were false
to adopt McCready prices interpretation
or or face destination
and so despite all that was happening
and
with Ellen White had said and the racism
blacks and whites were still into Maori
and they were still falling in love for
one
and
the science was against Ellen White and
so a great controversy would swirl in
the Adventist Church
um surrounding the implications that
black descended from human and honorable
into mixing
and so the question was has God revealed
Mr lyd envisioned that blacks were not
fully humans that was a huge controversy
and this also had implications for her
infallibility up to that point
Adventists where United was infallible
so whatever she said medicalally
scientifically spiritually whatever the
cases it was infallible
and so science was proven her wrong
what would they say about her in
politicism
and so two Adventist biologists
Dr Harold W clack and Dr Frank L Marsh
they got together to have a debate on
this issue
Harold Clark was for the historical View
and
Frank Marsh was for the new
interpretation that would save the face
of adventism
now just before this this debate
happened between a select few of
Adventists
presidents and and white estate people
big shots in the church
Frank Marsh actually had met with the GC
president at the time I think he was
Mick El Haney to explain to him the
gravity
of the situation and that if they do not
Embrace his new interpretation in the
face of the church they are going to
suffer a great and horrendous loss and
Ellen White's credibility would be
and so that is how this whole thing
unfolded and so when they got together
to debate brothers and sisters
even though Frank
decimated not not friend rather Harold
Pratt decimated Frank Marshall's
position and new interpretations
they had no choice but to embrace them
and so after
Frank Marsh's new interpretations of
positions were accepted
they began to spread it among the church
and in 1951 when when
the little was commissioned by the way
in a state the white right Ellen White
and her critics he requested all of
Marsha's papers arguments and stuff he
had done on the issue
and he used all of that fine tune them
and put us there as the new
interpretation
and that is why to this day
these new and twisted reinterpretations
of Ellen White
on amalgamation of minorities they come
the sacrosanct uh uh hats and truthful
statements or interpretations and every
SDA apologist
continues to repeat that
that is the the truth of the matter
brothers and sisters
it is not that they read her and his
sparkling contextually
they had to do a lot of reworking to
save the church just as they did from
the beginning all kinds of newspapes and
interpretations
so I have to save themselves from
destruction saved Eloise credibility Etc
and that paper is available on on the
Adventist archives you can read it to
yourself a lot of these hack SD
apologies they're not even read it
they don't even know these things exist
it's also recommended in the LNG
Ophelia read these things to yourself
educate yourself on these matters and
stop allowing yourself to be deceived by
this false ideologies
I have up here Thunder's book
um hiding in plain sight volume three
I'll put the link to that folks in the
description box down below where he
absolutely blows this out of the water
thousands of pages dedicated to
Seventh-Day adventism but here he talks
about in his book what he was just
mentioning this paper by shigley and you
mentioned what shigley's understanding
was before the pivot but you didn't
mention exactly what it was so here it
is in his book and he says this is
thunder talking given these facts that
we just explored what caused the change
of interpretation in 1947 so you've
mentioned that date a number of times
tonight 1947.
remember FD Nichols book came out in
1951.
so four years after this
shigley gives some insights as to why
this happened
he said quote controversy swirled around
the implication that blacks descended
from
the sexual Union of humans with animals
had God revealed to Ellen White in a
vision that blacks were not fully human
question mark close quote this was a
controversy that just would not die the
implications were undeniably racist and
great
Jason I guess all of your pioneers
everyone prior to FD nickel
shigley
Kilgore they were all confused
they were all confused none of them knew
how to read Ellen White properly they
missed that it was talking about inner
marriage
everyone did until FD nickel came along
and he was sent on a specific mission
to find a ghost Under The Rock
when you look for a ghost under every
Rock you're gonna find a ghost under
every Rock
that's what he was sent out to do he was
sent up hey come up with an excuse for
this now what can we do to essentially
deal back the blow that we're getting
there it is like you said you can check
out shigley's paper it's online it's in
the Adventist archives
I I just posted the link uh to for from
archives.org so you can grab shigley's
paper from there um and also most of us
if not all of us have the PDF here so if
you wanted to just email us and we'll
get it to you yeah so there's no problem
absolutely so you can see it for
yourself so if we're reading out of
context
please yeah let's point it out to us
yeah folks I encourage you to go back
watch this again if you need to
follow the historical chain for
yourselves
then you ask yourself when you hear the
SDA defenses to this who's looking at
both sides the whole spectrum of things
and who's just and we want to cut off
before that period and just focus in on
this new area here 90 years removed
you go look at the sources you see who
the clueless critics are
it's not us
so
fellas any last words that you would
like to share I know that we've been
going for about two and a half hours
here and so I'll let you guys say
anything that you'd like to close with
and then I will sign us off here from uh
what I hope will be a beneficial night
for days years weeks to come
yeah
um I'll say what I always say you know I
love y'all with the love of Christ even
if I disagree with you okay
um my concern for everyone
um is is very simple it's about truth
um is it is it true or is it not true
um is what has been said accurate in
terms of what element wrote in terms of
amalgamation of man and beasts
um are the defenses defensible
uh historically speaking and also uh in
terms of uh you know science and all the
all that okay
um yeah you have to decide for yourself
there has been ample evidence here from
Ellen White
from Ellen White's contemporaries both
inside and outside the church as what is
meant by amalgamation
what she meant by amalgamation of Mana
beast and what her contemporaries would
have understood by the term amalgamation
in between of Mana beasts it's it's that
simple and so what I would recommend for
anybody else is just be honest with the
evidence what does it say and if you
want to believe that what she says here
about amalgamation between man and Beast
isn't Offspring and you can make sense
of that defense from the egy to State
and God bless you you're more confused
than me you're smarter than me I can
leave it all I'll leave it on the floor
you can have it okay but for the rest of
us who uh can read and who can discern
uh what's being read here
um from a merely just what it says in
the literature you know
um then you have to look at what says
what's that what she says here and take
into consideration that she says it's
from the Throne of God this is light
from precious rays of light from the
Throne of God and if that is your god
who says that people who bear his image
are actually not his image bearers and
there should be no interaction with them
um either through inner marriage or or
anything else I would even look at the
stuff about leadership and whatever else
at that tonight no need for it
um but if you can look at that and
that's the guy that you serve
I don't have any dealings with you and I
can't look at you as a brother in Christ
because the guy that I serve has made
all human beings In His Image one flesh
of one blood we are all humans we all
belong to him and so my my uh my prayer
for all of you is that you bow your knee
to King Jesus right
um that you would acknowledge Him as
Savior as Lord you know and and be part
of the family
that's my question and my prayer for you
well as for me uh I'll Assembly say CMB
and everybody who's listening
we we do these these things out of love
and out of concern for
people's salvation
their socialization their mental health
and holistic development
and as you can see these things are
indefensible
these teachings beliefs and doctrines
and ideologies they are wrong
and there is no sensible way of
defending them
and so embrace the facts
acknowledge that you have been wrong
you're misled
embrace the facts repent embrace the
gospel and be saved enjoy the freedom
and the Liberty that comes with
embracing the biblical gospel
that comes with embracing Jesus Christ
and live in a holistic
human life that he would want us to live
hanging on to these false prophets and
these ideologies for their life is not
going to do anyone any good in the end
and so I hope that what we shared would
have educated a lot of you
would have
inspired you to do your own research
again and volume three I deal with these
things extensively I go through all of
the arguments all that they have written
onto matter
and I show how indefensible and how
wrong they are
and light biblical and historical truths
and so I hope that you are not taking
they'll be educated you will be equipped
and you'll continue to serve the god of
scripture
and not this God that Ellen White and
Adventist Church
have created
God bless you
Brothers thank you so much for being
here as always always a great time I'm
sure this will not be the last time Lord
willing that you guys will be on the
show
um so thank you I'm going to sign us off
here and uh close things down for the
night
thanks for having us brother
yeah
every day all right folks
so there you heard it
um hopefully that's beneficial I hope
that that will again like I said show
you who is looking at the whole of
History versus who is
um
isolating and contextualizing history I
wanted to respond to a couple uh
statements I hear uh in the comments
here toward the end
um you know it's like comments like
these
think you should invite the other side
to have a course of discussion about
this that that's why we started with
comments folks if you haven't watched
the whole show I encourage you to go
back to the beginning
um
we've done that folks we've done that we
you're talking to former seventh
Adventists here we know what the other
side says that's the whole point of me
showing comments at the beginning on the
video I made from a couple weeks ago is
because we know it we know it we know FD
Nichols arguments we literally just
showed you the history of the
development of the position
you guys you have to get over this you
got to get over this this shows your
Fidelity it's to the Adventist movement
it's not to Jesus Christ
it's to the Adventist movement
you have to defend these things you're
not able to just say yeah that's
despicable that's disgusting
and move along you have to defend it
and come up with these crazy excuses
that only make it worse
not seeing that the primary issue is
you're attributing this to God
you're saying that God said these things
it's not just merely Ellen White God
said this
no he didn't no he didn't
God did not flood the Earth because
certain races of people had the image of
God marred within them
you can try and spin that whatever way
you want you can try and make it sound
as soft as you want oh no that's talking
about being unequally yoked
so all the people today whose parents
were unequally yoked the image of God is
marred within them it just
it's crazy man it's crazy and it's sad
that we have to to do a stream like this
but this stream is going to live on the
facts are not going to change
the people who are unbiased who come to
this and see this say wow
they don't have to go through all these
mental gymnastics
the only people that have to do that are
the folks who have to defend adventism
tooth and nail because they know
if you start asking the question on this
or any of the other possible options
there's a lot here
it opens The Floodgate to say what else
was she wrong about
oh no
now we lose our Mark of being the
remnant Church
it's time to get serious about this
folks it's time to get serious about
this if you're an Adventist
be objective with this
go check all the resources that we
talked about tonight we talked about a
lot
we were not just using naysayers
we were predominantly going and doing
exactly what they what one of the
sources for example said to do
a pastor at that time
defending this saying no no what Ellen
White's statement's talking about was
that Offspring were produced through the
act of bestiality which is forbidden in
Leviticus 18.
this idea that oh no it was talking
about mixed mixed marriages being
unequally yoked okay so all the
Adventists misunderstood it for 90 years
okay
tomorrow
big announcement live stream not gonna
be super long but we're predominantly
going to be taking questions after a
little uh
I guess like a teaser if you will will
play
um
highly encourage you guys to be there an
anomalous Friday stream we don't
typically do streams on Fridays
big announcement big things coming and
it involves you
yes you
we need you guys because what we're
going to be discussing talking about
Vision moving forward
lots of cool things in store
lots of cool things possibilities
potential but we have to have you
we have to have you guys
we have big opportunities to make a big
splash
a big splash
we need you guys
so tune in tomorrow
I'm gonna be talking about some good
stuff next week my friend Chris
over at all things theology is going to
be on the show we're going to be talking
about solafide
the Adventists claimed that they affirm
solafide and you know they like to claim
oh we're Heirs of the Reformation
yeah you're gonna see that's not true so
don't lump the Adventist teaching an
idea in with us
um at least not classical Protestants do
not saddle us with that so that should
be a great show we also have on Thursday
we'll see if he shows up
the first Adventist that has been brave
enough to step up to the plate he will
have up to 15 minutes uninterrupted he
is going to give his best defense for
why Satan is typified by the scapegoat
of Leviticus 16. then after he's done we
will examine and go to scripture and see
if his um well the Adventist Church's
position
stands up to the biblical text so that
should be good as well a few other
things down the pike as well nothing
finalized so I'm not going to get into
that stuff but
as always the call as the Adventists
would say to us is that we need to come
out of her my people referring to the
of Babylon and we would turn that
back to them and say the exact same
thing except not about the of
Babylon but Ellen White Adventist come
out of her my people believe the gospel
come to know the true Christ his gospel
find Freedom in Christ it is amazing and
the Adventist Church is not dishing that
out sadly so come out of her my people
until next time as always God bless
foreign
[Music]